how's it going right my name's Porter
back welcome back is more dark cells
today we are going to fight the four
kings are you bros have been saying hey
pills good luck on the four kings my
thanks and then it's followed up like
hahahahaha yeah first of all you bros
wanted me to kill this hi dr that was
deepened our through it somewhere no no
no what are you doing you piece of [ __ ]
oh oh this is gotta be of my good time
what what the [ __ ] this squirt or
something oh there's that [ __ ] oh god
wait a second not ready not ready oh god
oh god I got okay
what are you doing oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is happening hi
oh sure I keep missing what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me all night hit the stone
now I'll do it
BAM that's the ride whoa I did a little
spinner even though I'm fat I think I
did it yeah okay one more come on eh wow
really did you just try to hit me there
we go
you looked up Oh dragon steel all right
Rach my net ba
I think smaug's armor is my favorite
armor so far it just looks so [ __ ]
cool oh god here it is yeah this is this
is the place
[ __ ] pots and [ __ ] looking fab master
1969 I have no quarrel with you sir just
[ __ ] kidding died yeah oh yeah right
between them Tatas I never got parried
before the again how dare you double
pair me [ __ ]
yes s FATA there you go Malik Oh God not
this bridge my ass is covering like half
the screen syriza how am I supposed to
see anything Oh what the [ __ ] are you
okay this is killer I can't what [ __ ]
that which temporarily curse allows
engagement with ghosts hopefully I can
touch these [ __ ] asses now I'm here
ready to kill you now no don't stab me
oh [ __ ] that's easy if anyone knows
where I'm going that'd be great I would
love to know to thank you
still don't have a [ __ ] clue where I
am oh dude who the [ __ ] are you you seek
the full Kings yah my god you Gardens is
the key to the sea you have you seen my
toes by the way oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh we must go deeper oh no I can go cool
that's cool
it's [ __ ] coal mine feel like this is
type of place you go to but you don't
come back from oh yeah
oh-oh-oh-oh chains get my [ __ ] tits
off what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what did you do drag ease so
that's a shortcut in I like how they're
all wet and [ __ ] so they all were in the
water right no mate no na na that's
[ __ ] awesome now and yet you really
need to stop farting that's [ __ ]
disgusting this is the boss fight
alright let's do it I'm ready for you
it's not the boss fight [ __ ]
ugliest fish I ever seen and I've seen
some ugly fishes just look at Miley
Cyrus whoa he has a [ __ ] vortex as a
shield god damn all I didn't last long
ha ha your battery ran out [ __ ] how the
hell did he get up there what is he
doing haha I might tickle your feet man
hey this is a hidden wall Oh
oh my god that's genius oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this don't throw me off the
bridge that's [ __ ] ass for one [ __ ]
thing ho jab GLaDOS I mean kook folly
for fun all what all those humanities
poof good
no really oh that's so [ __ ] good
isn't it really I'm glad I took like the
long way around so I wouldn't [ __ ]
die or she would stop peeing on the
[ __ ] carpet you ruined my life here
that you ruined my life
Almondine Jeff
hey how you doing
then jab la da dimly like jab like you
50 how that hurts so much you that is
[ __ ] Electrify my lips to infinity
you want to look at my titties you can't
a guy nay nay nay you fall into by
simple goal then yes I remember like
three hours ago when I was here without
a problem
nope don't stab a man when he's not
ready thank you
now I'm ready nice I don't and I'm not
ready I seriously don't remember there
supposed to be a hidden wall somewhere
there it is mine God ah I died rotating
a change a [ __ ] cake and a string
being lost like a [ __ ] idiot in Dark
Souls a novel by PewDiePie oh dude jab
lap on open Eminem my curiosity [ __ ]
swag swag city [ __ ] shake my titties
for you really really really quick
oh that looks great can't you just yo lo
yoloing is a bad idea kids fat man
coming through
thank you thank you oh god I made a it's
funny when you spent hours just trying
to get to the boss then you're gonna
spend another hour is just trying to
kill that little [ __ ] I just hope I do
enough damage to kill him
so what the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] let's do
it we didn't die
is it okay it'll be skinned oh god okay
we're coming hi don't know what the [ __ ]
that is
oh thank you like oh god it's [ __ ]
awesome
Oh God he grabbed my ass I'm so dead yep
oh god there's [ __ ] four of them I
forgot a holy [ __ ] oh my god this is
gonna be bad so [ __ ] cool boss oh
come on finish him
that's the charging a thing right there
it is I have to [ __ ] learn to dodge
that one I'm so into it
where's my dead body all the way over
there
god they're [ __ ] scary man oh [ __ ]
how do [ __ ]
come on baby oh god they have more
stamina
each one of them oh god maybe not it
will be that's tough bad oh no every
time George oh God
I got Oh che nevermind how yeah come on
baby
oh come on just die there we go
last one last one baby [ __ ] crazy where
is he
Charlie ah south
don't you see my faith brah I will
charge you like I charge your mom -
[ __ ] oh god I suck so much
watch another even roll me [ __ ] rolling
when you got DPS [ __ ] yeah I got
a little carried away I'm so sorry
there's a worst fight ever
I [ __ ] tanked and I can just got
lucky I I know I just got lucky
oh yeah baby
I broke my controller oh no it's fixed
don't worry what's up oh hey where the
[ __ ] were you all this time I missed you
man
I missed you [ __ ] love this mask it's
awesome
I love this weapon but we're gonna go
and get another one
I don't know it's only because I have a
lot of strength and I don't think this
is weapon is a string weapon we're going
back to the hello of Earth and no I do
not talk about Justin Bieber's vagina ah
the memories of this place are just
coming back I hate this place or design
and smoke has been the worst boss but
this has been the worst area one of
these walls are not like the
well this place is bad is Oh God haha
anything about the tree branches no one
has been here for a long time this is my
kingdom [ __ ] is secure I'm so sorry so
follow me for let's go oh [ __ ] my ass
out come on why isn't parachutes
invented it feels actually surprisingly
good try it doesn't taste good hahaha
that's adorable man you will die a
horrible - nothing keep falling over oh
my god
Darwin didn't get to you anything oh god
I'm so sorry about killing your children
and your dad and your grandma and your
face oh I don't ever survive with that
little help
all right we're over now Ashley yes this
is why we wanted to go it's not a band
fire the male of the tit we're
underneath the water and [ __ ] this game
just keeps blowing my mind man he
beautiful I've seen a lot of shape butts
in my life at that bad just the most
beautiful thing but oh god is Hydra [ __ ]
that how are we underwater so if this is
the end of the ocean what the hell is
down there that scares me man oh [ __ ] my
deck Ennis [ __ ]
enough enough thank you
don't you dare cars my dick
okay I think it's time to stop yep
definitely time to stop all right like
enjoy watching ruff professed
you